the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
in the in the twelfth lecture we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about maxima and minima let's finish up
what we did last time we really only
just started with maxima and minima and
then we're going to talk about related
rates so right now I want to give you
some examples of max-min problems and
we're going to start with a with a
fairly basic one so what's the the thing
about max-min problems the main thing is
that we're asking you to do a little bit
more of the interpretation of word
problems so many of the problems are
expressed in terms of words and so in
this case we have we have a wire which
is length one cut in two into two pieces
and then each piece encloses the square
sorry and closes a square and the
problem so this is the setup and the
problem is to find the the largest area
enclosed
all right so here's the problem
now in all of these cases in all these
cases there's a bunch of words and your
job is typically to draw a diagram okay
so the first thing you want to do is to
draw a diagram in this case it can be
fairly schematic
here's your unit length and when you
draw the diagram you're going to have to
pick variables so those are really the
two main tasks to set up the problem so
you're drawing a diagram this is like
word problems of old in grade school
through high school draw a diagram and
name name the variables so we'll be
doing a lot of that today so here's my
unit length and if I'm going to choose
the variable X to be the length of one
of the pieces of wire and that makes the
other piece one minus X and that's
pretty much the whole diagram except
that there's something that we did with
the wire after we cut it in half namely
we built two little boxes out of it like
this these are our squares and their
side lengths are x over four and one
minus x over core all right so so far so
good and now we have to think well we
want to find the largest area so I need
a formula for area in terms of the
variables that I've described and so
that's the last thing I'll give the
letter A as the label for the area and
then the area is just the square of x
over four plus the square of 1 minus X
whoops
that's strange two got in there over
four all right
okay so far so good now the instinct
that you will have and I'm going to
yield to that instinct is we should
charge ahead and just differentiate all
right that's all right we'll find the
critical points so we know that those
are the important points so we're going
to find the critical points in other
words we take the derivative we set the
derivative of a with respect to X equal
to zero all right so if I do that
differentiation I get the well so the
first one x squared over 16 that's
that's eight sorry
that's x over eight right that's the
derivative of this and if I
differentiate this I get well the
derivative of 1 minus x squared is two
times 1 minus x times a minus 1 so it's
minus 1 minus x over 8 all right so
there are two minus signs in there I'll
let you ponder that differentiation
which I did by the chain rule all right
hang on a sec ok just wait until we're
done all right so here's the derivative
all right is there a problem
right so there's a 1/16 here this is x
squared over 16 and so it's 2x over 8
over 16 sorry which has an 8 all right
okay so it's okay all right so now this
is equal to zero if and only if if and
only if X is equal to 1 minus X that's
2x is equal to 1 or in other words X is
1/2 all right so there's our critical
point so x equals 1/2 is the critical
point and the critical value which is
what you get when you evaluate a at 1/2
is 1/2 divided by 4 that's 1/8 all right
so that's 1/8 squared plus 1/8 squared
which is 1 over 32 all right so so far
so good but we're not done yet
all right we're not done all right so
why aren't we done because we haven't
checked the end points all right so
let's check the end points now in this
problem the end points are really sort
of excluded the ends are between 0 & 1
here that's the possible lengths of the
of the cut and so what we should really
be doing is evaluating in the limit so
that would be the right hand limit as X
goes to 0 of a and if you plug in x
equals 0 what you get here is 0 plus 1
over 4 squared which is 1/6
right and similarly at the other end
that's one - one from from from the left
we get 1/4 squared plus 0 which is also
1/16 so what you see is that the
schematic picture of this function this
isn't even so far off from being the
right picture here is that it's level
here is 1/16 and then it dips down and
goes up right this is 1/2 this is 1 and
this level here is 1/2 that this is a 1
over 32 all right so we did not find
when we found the critical point we did
not find the largest area and closed
we found the least area enclosed so if
you don't pay attention to what the
function looks like not only will you
about half the time get the wrong answer
you'll get the absolute worst answer
you'll get the one which is the polar
opposite from what you want all right so
you have to pay a little bit of
attention to the function that you've
got and in this case it's just very
schematic it dips down and goes up and
that's true pretty much most functions
they're fairly simple they maybe only
have one critical point they only turn
around once but then maybe the critical
point is the maximum or maybe it's the
minimum or maybe it's neither
in fact so we'll we'll be discussing
that maybe some other time all right so
what we find here is that we have the
least area enclosed and closed is the 60
is sorry 1/32 right and this is true
when x equals 1/2 so these are equal
squares
all right and most when there's only one
square which is more or less the
limiting situation if one of the one of
the pieces disappears all right now so
that's that's the the first kind of
example and I just want to make one more
comment about terminology before we go
on and I will introduce it with the
following question what is the minimum
all right
so so what is the minimum yeah
right the lowest value of the function
so the answer to that question is 1 over
32 okay now the problem with this
question and you will so that refers to
the minimum value all right but then
there's this other question which is
where is the minimum and the answer to
that is x equals 1/2 okay so one of them
is the minimum point and the other one
is the minimum value all right so there
there are two separate things now the
problem is that people are sloppy and
especially since you usually find the
the critical point first and the value
that is plugging in for a second
people will stop short and they'll give
the wrong answer to the question for
instance now both questions are
important to answer you just need to
have a word to put there so this is a
little bit careless when we say what is
the minimum some people will say 1/2 and
that's literally wrong they know what
they mean but it's just wrong and when
people ask this question they're being
sloppy anyway they should maybe be a
little clearer and say what's the
minimum value or where is the value
achieved it's achieved at or whereas the
minimum value achieved where is the min
achieved would be a better way of
phrasing this this second question so
that it it has an unambiguous answer and
when people ask you for the minimum
point they're also well so why is that
we call the minimum point we have this
word critical point which is what x
equals 1/2 is in critical value and so
I'm making those same distinctions here
but there's another notion of a minimum
point
and this is an alternative if you like
the minimum point is the point 1/2 1
over 32 right that's a point on the
graph it's the point well so well that
graph is way up there but I'll just put
it on there that's that's this point and
you might say min there and you might
point to this point and you might say
max similarly this one might be a max
okay so in other words so that what this
means is simply that people are a little
sloppy and sometimes they mean one thing
and sometimes they mean another all
right and you're just stuck with this
because there'll be some authors who
will say one thing and some people will
mean another and you just have to live
with this little bit of annoying
ambiguity all right yeah okay so that's
a good very good so here we go fine to
the largest area enclosed so that's sort
of a trick question isn't it
so there are there are there various
that's a that's a good thing to ask
that's sort of a trick question why
because according to the rules we're
trapped between the two Maxima it's
something which is strictly below so in
other words one answer to this question
would be and this is the answer that I
would probably give is 1/16 but that's
not really true because that's only in
the limit
as X goes to zero or as X goes to one -
and if you like most is when you've only
got one square which it breaks the rules
of the problem all right
so essentially it's a trick question
right but I would I would answer it this
way because that's the most interesting
part of the answer which is that it's
1/16 and it occurs really when you only
when when one of the squares disappears
- nothing's all right so now let's do
another example here and I just want to
illustrate the sort of the second the
second style or the second type of
question yeah
the question is since the question was
what was the largest area why did we
find the least area the reason is that
when we go about our procedure of
looking for the least or the most will
automatically find both because we don't
know which one is which until we compare
values and actually it's much more to
your advantage to figure out that much
both the maximum and the minimum
whenever you answer such a question
because otherwise you'll you won't
understand the behavior of the function
very well
so the question we've started out with
one question we answered both we answer
two questions we answer the question of
what the largest and the and the and the
smallest value was
yes one can also use the question is can
we use the second derivative test and
the answer is yes we can in fact you can
actually also stare at this and see that
it's a sum of square so it's always
curving up it's a parabola with a
positive second coefficient so you can
differentiate this twice if you do
you'll get 1/8 plus another 8 and you'll
get a 16th so the second derivative is 6
is 1/16 is 1/4 and that's an acceptable
way of figuring it out all I'll mention
the second derivative test again in this
second example so let me talk about a
second example so again this is going to
be another question the question is when
I say minimum or maximum point which
will I mean yeah so that that's the
quiet is repeated the question so the
question is when I say minimum point
what will I mean okay and the answer is
that for the purposes of this class I
will probably avoid saying that but I
will say probably where is the minimum
achieved just in order to avoid that if
I actually said it I often am referring
to the graph and I mean this and in fact
when you get your little review for the
second exam I'll say exactly that on the
review sheet okay and I'll make this
very clear when we were doing this
however I just want to prepare you for
the fact that in real life and even me
when I'm talking colloquially when I say
what's the minimum point of something I
might actually be mixing it up with this
with this other notion here all right
okay so let's do another example so this
is an example to get us used to the
notion of of constraints so we have so
consider a box without a top or if you
like we're going to find the box without
a top with least surface area for a
fixed volume all right find the box
without a top with least surface area
for a fixed volume the procedure for
working this out is the following you
make this diagram and you set up the
variables all right in this case we're
going to have four names of variables
all right we have four letters that we
have to choose and we'll choose them in
a kind of a standard way all right so
first I have to tell you one more thing
which is something that you'll that we
could calculate separately but I'm just
going to give it to you in advance which
is that it turns out that the best box
has a square bottom and that's going to
get rid of one of our variables for us
so it's got a square bottom and so let's
draw a picture of it so here's our box
well I guess that goes down like this
almost maybe I should get a little
farther down all right
all right so here's our box let's
correct that just a bit all right so now
what about the dimensions of this box
well this is going to be X and this is
very foreshortened but it's also X the
bottom is X by X it's the same
dimensions and then the vertical
dimension is why okay so far so good now
I have I taught us two two more letter
names I want to compute the volume all
right the volume is the base is x
squared and height is y so there's the
volume and then the area the area is the
area of the bottom which is x squared
that's the bottom and then there are the
four sides and the four sides are
rectangles of dimensions XY so it's four
XY all right so these are the sides and
remember there's no top so that's our
setup so now the difference between this
problem and the last problem is that
there are two variables floating around
namely x and y which are not determined
but there's what's called a constraint
here namely we fixed the relationship
between x and y and so that means that
we can solve for for y in terms of X so
Y is equal to V divided by x squared and
then we can plug that into the formula
for a so here we have a which is x
squared plus 4x times V over x squared
question yeah the questions will you
need to know this intuitively no that's
a that's something that I would have to
give to you I mean it's it's it's
actually true that that a lot of things
the the correct answer is something
symmetric in this last problem the
minimum turned out to be exactly halfway
in between because there were sort of
equal demands from the two sides and
similarly here what happens is if you
elongate one side you get less it's it's
it actually is a involved with a two
variable problem namely if you have a
rectangle and you have a certain amount
of length associated with it what's the
optimal thing you can do with that but I
won't in other words the optimal
rectangle the least perimeter rectangle
turns out to be a square that's a little
subproblem that leads you to this square
bottom but but so that would have been a
separate maximum problem which I'm
skipping because I want to do this
slightly more interesting one all right
okay so now here's our formula for a and
now I want to follow the same procedure
as before namely we'll look for the
critical point or points so let's take a
look so again a is x squared plus 4v
over X and a prime is 2x minus 4v over x
squared so if we set that equal to zero
we get 2x equals to v over x squared so
to X cubed well how did that happen to
change into two interesting
guess that's wrong okay right so this is
X cubed is equal to 2 V all right and so
X is equal to 2 to the 1/3 V to the 1/3
all right so this is the critical point
so we are not done right we're not done
because we don't even know whether this
is going to give us the worst box or the
best box from this point of view the one
uses the most surface area or the least
so let's check the ends right away to
see what's happening so can somebody
tell me what the ends what the end
values of X are where does X range from
what's the smallest xep yeah okay the
claim was that the largest X could be
route a because somehow there's this x
squared here in it and you can't get any
further passing that but there's a key
feature here of this problem which is
that a is variable the only thing that's
fixed in the problem is V okay so if V
is fixed what do you know about X yeah
X is greater than zero yeah the lower
endpoint that's safe because that has to
do geometrically with the fact that we
don't have any boxes with negative
dimensions that would be refused by the
post office definitely it over and above
the empty top which they wouldn't accept
either
it's true that X is less than square
root of B over Y so that's using this
relationship but notice that Y is equal
to V over x squared so 0 to infinity I
just got a guess there over here that's
right here's the upper limit so that
this is really important to realize this
is most problems most problems the
variable if it doesn't have a limitation
usually just goes out to infinity and
infinity is a very important end for the
problem it's usually an easy end to the
problem - all right so there's the
possibility that we push all the way
down to x equals 0 we'll get a better
box it would be a very strange box a
little bit like our vanishing enclosure
and maybe an infinitely long box also
very inconvenient one might be the best
box we'll have to see all right so let's
just take a look at what happens so
we're looking at a at 0 plus right and
that's x squared plus 4v over X with X
at 0 plus so what happens to that notice
right here this is going to infinity all
right so this is infinite so that turns
out to be a bad box all right let's take
a look at the other end so this is x
squared plus 4v over X X going to
infinity and again this term here means
that this thing is infinite so the shape
of this thing I'll draw this tiny little
schematic diagram over here the shape of
this thing is like this all right and so
when we find that one turnaround point
which happened to be at this strange
point 2/3 of 2 to the 1/3 sorry V to the
1/3 that is going to be the minimum
all right so we've just discovered that
it's the minimum which is just what we
were hoping for this is going to be the
optimal box now up since you asked
earlier and since it's worth checking
this as well let's also check an
alternative justification so an
alternative to checking ends is the
second derivative test I do not
recommend the second derivative test I
try my best when I give you problems to
make it really hard to apply the second
derivative test but in this example that
function is simple enough so that it's
perfectly okay if you take the
derivative here remember this was
whatever it was 2x minus 4v over x
squared if I take the second derivative
it's two plus a 8v over X cubed and
that's positive so this thing is concave
up and that's consistent with its being
the critical point as a min is a minimum
point C now I almost said is a min it's
opposed to minimum point so watch out
yes
why here you're one step ahead of me the
question is is this the answer to the
question would we have to give Y and a
and so on and so forth so again I want
to this is something that I want to
emphasize and take my time with right
now because it depends what kind of
real-life problem you're answering what
kind of answer is appropriate so so far
we've found the critical point we
haven't found the critical value we
haven't found the dimensions of the box
okay so I going to spend a little bit
more time on this exactly in order to
address these questions so first of all
the value of y so so far we have X is 2
to the 1/3 V to the 1/3 and certainly if
you're going to build the box you also
want to know what the Y value is the Y
value is going to be let's see well it's
it's V over x squared so that's V
divided by 2 to the 1/3 V to the 1/3
squared which comes out to be 2 to the
minus 2/3 V to the 1/3 okay so there's
the Y value on top of that we could
figure out the value of a all right so
that's also perfectly reasonable part of
the answer depending on what one is
interested in you might care how much
money it's going to cost you to build
this box this optimal box and so you
plug in the value of a so a let's see is
up here it's x squared plus 4 V over X
so that's going to be 2 to the 1/3 B to
the 1/3 squared plus 4 V divided by 2 to
the 1/3 B to the 1/3 all right and if
you work that all out what you get turns
out to be 3 times 2 to the 1/3 V to the
2/3 all right
so so if you like one way of answering
this question is is these three
these three things that would be the
minimum point corresponding to the graph
that would be that the answer this
question but the reason why I'm carrying
it out in such detail is I want to show
you that there are much more meaningful
ways of answering this question so let
me let me explain that
so so let me go through some more
meaningful answers here the the first
more meaningful answer is the following
sort of idea simply then what are known
as dimensionless variables so the first
thing that you notice is the scaling law
the a divided by V to the 2/3 is the
thing that's a dimensionless quantity
that happens to be 3 times 2 to the 1/3
okay
so that's one thing if you want to
expand a volume you'll have to expand
the area by the 2/3 power of the volume
and if you think of the area as being in
say cubic sorry square inches and the
the volume of the box as being in cubic
inches then you can see that this is a
dimensionless quantity and you have a
dimensionless number here which is a
characteristic independent of what in V
were the other dimensionless quantity is
the ratio of Y to X next to Y all right
so again that's that's inches divided by
inches and it's 2 to the 1/3 V to the
1/3 divided by 2 to the minus 2/3 V to
the 1/3 which happens to be 2 all right
so this is actually the best answer to
the question and it shows you that the
box is a 2 to 1 box if this is 2 and
this is 1 that's the good box and that
is just the shape if you like
and it's the optimal ship and I
certainly that aesthetically that's that
that's the cleanest answer to the
question all right there was a question
right here yes
could could you repeat that I couldn't
hear
the question is could we have gotten the
answer if we weren't told that the
bottom was square the answer is yes in
1802 with multivariable you would have
to have three letters here an X a Y and
a Z if you like and then you'd have to
work with all three of them all right so
I separated out into one there's a
there's a separate one variable problem
that you can do for the base and then
this is a second one variable problem
for this other thing and it's just two
consecutive one variable problems that
solve the multi variable problem or as I
say in multivariable calculus you can
just do it all in one step
all right yeah why did I divide X by Y
rather than Y by X or or in any so again
when I was aiming for was dimensionless
quantities so x and y are measured in
the same units and also the proportions
of the box so that's another word for
this as proportions are something that's
universal independent of the volume V
it's something you can say about any box
at any scale whether it be you know
something by cristo and you know in the
common to do some fancy the proportions
is with geometric problems typically
when when there's a scaling to the
problem where the answer is the same at
small scales and at large scales this is
capturing that so that's why the via the
ratios are what's capturing that and
that's why it's aesthetically the nicest
thing to ask okay
it unfortunately this number is a really
is a really obscure number so it doesn't
the question is what does this tell us
the only thing that I want to emphasize
is what's on the left hand side here
which is the it's the area to the 2/3
power of the volume so it's a
dimensionless quantity that happens to
be this if you do this for example in
general with planar diagrams
circumference to area is the is a is a
bad ratio to take what you want to take
is the square of circumference to area
because the square of circumference has
the same dimensions that is say inches
squared to area which has which is in
square inches so again it's these
dimensionless quantities that you want
to to cook up and those are the ones
that will have universal properties
there's a the most famous of these is
that the circle in is the encloses the
most area for its circumference and
again that's only true if you measure
air you take the square of the
circumference you do the unit's
correctly all right ok anyway okay so
we're here we've got a shape we've got
an answer to this question and I now
want to do this problem well let's put
it this way I wanted to do this problem
by a different method I think I'll take
the time to do it so I want to I want to
do this problem by a slightly different
method here so here's example two by
implicit differentiation so the same
example but now I'm going to do it by
implicit differentiation and I now I'll
tell you the advantages and the
disadvantages to this method here so the
situation is you have to start the same
way
so here was the starting place of the
problem all right
and we're taking the we're aiming the
goal was the minimum of a with V
constant so this was the situation that
we were in and now what I want to do is
just differentiate all right the
function y is implicitly a function of X
so I can differentiate the first
expression and that yields 0 is equal to
2x y plus x squared Y prime right so
this is giving me my implicit formula
for Y Prime so Y prime is equal to minus
2x Y divided by x squared or in other
words minus 2y divided by X and then I
also have the derivative of a with
respect to X now you may notice I'm not
using Prime's quite as much because I
all of the variables are varying and so
here I'm emphasizing that the
differentiation is with respect to the
variable X and this becomes 2x plus 4y
plus 4x y prime so again this is using
the product rule and now I can plug in
for what Y prime is which is right above
it so this is 2x plus 4y plus 4x times
minus 2 y over X ok and that's equal to
0 and so let's get that gather that
together
so what do we have we have 2x plus 4y
and then all together this is 8 minus 8y
equals 0 so that's the same thing as 2x
is equal to 4y right the minus 4y goes
to the other side and so x over y is
equal to 2 so this I claim well so you
have to decide for yourself but I claim
that this is faster all right it's
faster and also it gets to the heart of
the matter which is the scale-invariant
proportions which is basically also
nicer so it gets to the nicer answer
also so those are that those are the
advantages that this has so it's faster
and it gets to this I'm going to call it
nicer and the disadvantage is did not
check whether this critical point is a
max min or neither okay so we didn't
quite finish the problem but we got to
the answer very fast yeah question
how would you check it well so it gives
you a candidate the answer is so the
question is how would you check it the
answer is that for this particular
problem the only way to do it is to do
something like this
all right so in other words you doesn't
save you that much time but with many
many examples you actually can tell
immediately that if the two ends the
thing is is say zero and inside it's
positive things like that so in many
many cases this is just as good all
right okay so now I'm going to change
subjects here but the subject that I'm
going to talk about next is almost is
very very closely linked namely I talked
about implicit differentiation now we're
going to just talk about dealing with
lots of variables and rates of change so
essentially we're going to talk about
the same type of thing so I'm going to
tell you about a subject which is called
related rates which is really just
another excuse for getting used to
setting up variables and equations so
here we go
related rates and I'm going to
illustrate this with one example today
one one tomorrow so here's my example
for today so here again this is going to
be a police from but this is going to be
a word prom but and sorry I'm not don't
want to scare you know police
well there was police in the story that
they're not present so but I'm going to
draw it immediately with a diagram
because because I'm going to save us the
trouble although you know the point here
is to get from the words to the to the
diagram okay so you have the police and
they're 30 feet from the road and here's
the road
and you're coming along here in your
let's see in your car going in this
direction here and the police have radar
which is bouncing off of your car and
what they read off is that you have that
you're 50 feet away all right they also
know that you're approaching along the
line of the radar at a rate of 80 feet
per second okay now the question is are
you speeding right
that's the question so so when you're
speeding by the way 95 feet per second
is about 65 miles per hour so that's the
that's the threshold here so so what I
want to do now is show you how you set
up a problem like this all right
this distance is 50 this is 30 and
because it's the distance to a straight
line you know that this is a right angle
so we know that this is a right triangle
and this is set up to be a right
triangle which is which is an easy one a
3 4 5 right triangle just so that we can
do the computations easily all right so
now the question is how do we put the
letters in to make this problem work to
figure out what the rate of changes and
now let me let me explain that right now
and we will actually do the computation
next time so the first thing is you have
to understand what's changing and what's
not and we're going to use T for time in
seconds ok and now
an important distance here is the
distance to this foot of this
perpendicular so I'm going to name that
X all right I'm going to give that
letter X now X is varying the reason why
I need a letter for it except as opposed
to this for T is that it's going to have
a rate of change with respect to T and
in fact it's related to the question is
whether DX DT is is faster or slower
than 95 okay so that's the thing that's
very now there's something else that's
varying this distance here is also
varying so we need a letter for that we
do not need a letter for this because
it's never changing we're assuming the
police are parked they're not ready to
roar out and catch you just yet and
there's certainly not in motion when
they've got their radar guns aimed at
you so you know sort of need to know
something about the Sociology and style
of police when they're okay so you need
to know know things about the real world
now the last bit is what about this this
ad here so this is how fast you're
approaching now that's measured along
the radar gun I claim that that's D by
DT of this quantity here so this D is
also changing that's why we needed a
letter for it too so next time we'll
just put that all together and compute
DX by DT